[Music]
have you ever tried to picture an ideal
world one without war poverty or crime
if so you're not alone
Plato imagined an enlightened Republic
ruled by philosopher Kings many
religions promised bliss in the
afterlife
and throughout history various groups
have tried to build paradise on earth
Thomas More's 1516 book utopia gave this
concept a name Greek for no place though
the name suggested impossibility modern
scientific and political progress raised
hopes of these dreams finally becoming
reality but time and time again they
instead turned into nightmares of war
famine and oppression and as artists
began to question utopian thinking the
genre of dystopia the not good place was
born one of the earliest dystopian works
is Jonathan Swift's Gulliver's Travels
throughout his journey
Gulliver encounters fictional societies
some of which at first seem impressive
but turn out to be seriously flawed on
the flying island of Laputa scientists
and social planners pursue extravagant
and useless schemes while neglecting the
practical needs of the people below and
the who Wynnum who live in perfectly
logical harmony have no tolerance for
the imperfections of actual human beings
with his novel Swift established a
blueprint for dystopia imagining a world
where certain trends in contemporary
society are taken to extremes exposing
their underlying flaws and the next few
centuries would provide plenty of
material industrial technology that
promised to free laborers imprisoned
them in slums and factories instead
while tycoons grew richer than kings by
the late 1800s many feared where such
conditions might lead HG Wells The Time
Machine imagined upper classes and
workers evolving into separate species
while Jack London's the iron heel
portrayed a tyrannical oligarchy ruling
over impoverished masses
the new century brought more exciting
and terrifying changes medical advances
made it possible to transcend biological
limits while mass media allowed instant
communication between readers and the
public in Aldous Huxley's brave new
world citizens are genetically
engineered and conditioned to perform
their social roles while propaganda and
drugs keep the society happy it's clear
some crucial human element is lost but
the best-known dystopias were not
imaginary at all as Europe suffered
unprecedented industrial warfare new
political movements took power some
promised to erase all social
distinctions while others sought to
unite people around a mythical heritage
the results were real-world dystopias
where life passed under the watchful eye
of the state and death came with
ruthless efficiency to any who didn't
belong many writers of the time didn't
just observe these horrors but lived
through them in his novel we Soviet
writer Yevgeny zem yatin described a
future where free will and individuality
were eliminated banned in the USSR the
book inspired authors like George Orwell
who fought on the front lines against
both fascism and communism while his
novel Animal Farm directly mocked the
Soviet regime the classic 1984 was a
broader critique of totalitarianism
media and language and in the USA
Sinclair Lewis's it can't happen here
envisioned how easily democracy gave way
to fascism in the decades after world
war two writers wondered what new
technologies like atomic energy
artificial intelligence and space travel
meant for humanity's future contrasting
with popular visions of shining progress
dystopian science fiction expanded to
films comics and games
robots turned against their creators
while TV screens broadcast deadly mass
entertainment workers toiled in space
colonies above an earth of depleted
resources and overpopulated crime
plagued cities yet politics was never
far away
works like dr. Strangelove and Watchmen
explored the real threat of nuclear war
while V for Vendetta and The Handmaid's
Tale warned how easily our rights could
disappear in a crisis and today's
dystopian fiction continues to reflect
modern anxieties about inequality
climate change government power and
global epidemics so why bother with all
this pessimism because at their heart
dystopias are cautionary tales not about
some particular government or technology
but the very idea that humanity can be
molded into an ideal shape think back to
the perfect world you imagined did you
also imagine what it would take to
achieve how would you make people
cooperate and how would you make sure it
lasted now take another look does that
world still seem perfect
you
[Music]